-Our next guest has his
comedy special,
"Jesus Trejo: Stay At Home Son,"
available now on Showtime.
Making his "Tonight Show" debut,
please welcome the very funny
Jesus Trejo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What's up, everybody?
My mom had her
first Zoom doctor meeting.
I thought that was interesting.
And she's not tech savvy,
so I sat here.
Mom's here.
We're looking at the laptop.
Thing's done. I close it.
I look to my mom.
I go, "Mom, what did you think?"
And she looks at me and goes,
"Who was that guy?"
Adorable.
Everything is so different.
Like, the roles, for me,
switched during this time.
During quarantine,
everything switched.
Like, I'm the parent,
and my parents feel like
they're the kids.
Like, my mom has never been
that active before.
Like, "Can I go outside?"
"No, you can't go outside.
You'll get sick."
"Can I go outside for
a little bit?"
"No, you can't do that."
"Please? I want to go outside."
I'm like, "Mom, you can't."
And then my little heart,
as a parent, just broke.
I'm like, "Alright,
you can go outside,
but stay where
I can see you, please.
Don't go too far.
If you see somebody,
you run back in the apartment."
"Okay, I can do that."
But I used this downtime to do
everything I wanted to do
and I never got a chance to do.
Like, I read some books.
I saw some movies.
I cleaned my belly button.
That was cool.
Had the cubic zirconia in there.
Yeah.
Yeah, I even cleaned
my refrigerator.
It felt good.
-Whoo!
-Yeah, thank you.
And I realized something.
I realized I've been working on
the same bottle of mustard
since I was a kid.
Like, this bottle has been part
of my life a long time, man.
And I don't even know
if it's bad or not
'cause it's mustard, right?
That's what it
tastes like, I guess.
I think we got into
mustard too early.
We didn't let them
fully invent it.
Think about mustard.
Think about mustard
for a little bit.
Yellow mustard,
spicy mustard, Dijon mustard.
Guys, keep going. You're close.
If you ever tasted mustard
and it was delicious,
that's honey mustard for sure.
And honey is doing all the
lifting in that relationship.
Yeah, man.
Did you guys know that mustard
was initially invented
to clean jewelry?
That's not true,
but you believe it
'cause you know what
it tastes like.
Mustard is the only condiment
that you can, like,
spill on yourself,
and people love to point it out
and ruin your day.
Like, "Hey, man,
you got mustard on your shirt."
You're like, "Oh, dang it, man."
"Have a good one."
"Screw you, man."
But if you ever feel lonely,
you want to make some friends,
put a little mustard
on your shirt, hit the town.
Just wait.
Like, "Hey, man,
you got mustard on your shirt."
You got to act surprised.
"Oh, dang it, man.
What's your name?
My name is Jesus Trejo."
Friendship made.
Here's a question.
Is every deli famous?
I saw them open
a brand-new deli,
and it already said
"World famous."
What I wanted to say was,
"Hey, deli, relax.
Enjoy the journey, man.
You'll get there.
What's the rush?"
Yeah, man. I like food a lot.
This is all going to be
food, so -- Alright.
Yeah. I used to be
addicted to cupcakes.
I used to be really, really
I ate one every day.
Took Sundays off
'cause diabetes.
Now I'm into muffins.
I feel like the older you get,
your palate becomes
a little more refined, you know?
And a muffin is just
a brave cupcake, you know?
It got to the point
where it realized
it didn't need
sprinkles or frosting
and it would be delicious.
I love a muffin, man.
Favorite part about the
muffin -- taking the paper off,
the little corduroys,
you know...
Just seeing the muffin
all vulnerable right there,
just chillin',
stretch marks on the side.
I'm like, "I like that, muffin."
Muffin looking like
it's been wearing
jeans and a tight belt all day.
You got to relax, man.
I had hot dogs recently.
I don't want to brag, but I had
hot dogs with my folks.
And, yeah,
I was excited about it.
And my dad's like,
"Do we have mustard?"
I'm like, "Hell yeah.
You'll see
the bottle right over here.
And he came back.
He's like,
"Hey, man, this is bad.
Water came out."
I was like, "Dad,
you got to shake it.
You got to boot it up.
You got to let it know
you're about to use it.
You surprised it.
Let somebody squeeze you,
see if water doesn't come out.
You weren't ready, right?"
He's like, "No. It's bad.
It got brown spots."
I'm like, "It's deli mustard
now -- world famous."
Thank you, guys. That's my time.
Appreciate you. Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jesus Trejo!
For more info,
go to jesustrejo.com.